hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
you might remember a couple weeks ago we
did a slight detour from our usual
topics I'm not exactly sure what our
usual topics are but we took a detour
back into the ancient world we talked
with Ed Watts about the decline of the
Roman Republic and of course one of the
interesting things about ancient history
or history at all is its resonances with
contemporary history so today we're
going to go back to the ancient world I
had a good time in that previous podcast
I hope you did too so today we're gonna
go back but with a slightly different
twist connecting it to our issues of
technology and artificial intelligence
in fact we're gonna be asking what were
robots and AI systems like 2,500 years
ago now you might be thinking to
yourself
there weren't any robots or artificial
intelligences back in ancient Greece and
Rome and you're correct but that didn't
stop people from talking about them the
mythology the stories the poems of
ancient Greece and Rome were in some
sense similar to the science fiction and
fantasy of today they allowed the
authors to let their imaginations roam
free
and they would often stop at the point
where they were talking about
constructed beings in the shape or
manner of humans so today's guest is
Adrian Mayer who is a historian of
ancient scientist and a classical
folklorist at Stanford
she's very interesting at this because
he not only reads the ancient texts but
also consults the archaeological
paleontological evidence so we're gonna
talk about all the different appearances
in Greek mythology of robot-like
creatures and of course being that with
Greek mythology there was always a
lesson right there is always something
went wrong because somebody did
something bad and it what it reflects is
the fact that the worries or the
interesting conundrums that face you
when you talk about human-like machines
were just as relevant 2500 years ago
when there weren't no such machines as
they are now so it's at the very least
fun and hopefully a little bit more than
fun to think about what was prefigured
in ancient mythology about our current
worries about artificial intelligence
robots and how they're changing society
so I think this is a fun episode we'll
also touch a little bit at the end on a
different book that Adrienne wrote
previously about Amazon's
Amazon's of course our mythological
female warriors there was no society
that was all female warriors but she
makes the case quite convincingly that
there were female warriors historically
upon whom the Amazon legends were based
so it's and yet another example of how
things going on in the ancient world
still have their reflections today so I
think this is a good mind-expanding
episode even if it's a little bit off of
our usual beaten path so let's go
[Music]
Adrian mayor welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you for inviting me so
we've had plenty of people on the show
you know there's a lot of scientists
technologists etc but we have this
special time that we're gonna have with
you because you've written a book about
ancient ideas of technology robots
cyborgs artificial intelligence but for
the most part correct me if I'm wrong
these are not actual stuff that people
built these are mythological tales these
are these are completely made-up stories
is that right well you know I wondered
whether it was possible that the
concepts the ideas about creating
artificial life automatons and robots
even even artificial intelligence
wondered if those ideas were thinkable
before the technology made such
enterprises possible and I did find that
remarkably if you look at mythology as
early as the time of Homer and now we're
talking about 750 to 650 BC the first
writings in the ancient Greek world a
group of ancient Greek myths were
envisioning how to imitate and imitate
nature and make automatons by means of
biotech name and that's a Greek word
that means life through crafts that
would be what we now call biotechnology
and they called them beings that were
made not born
so in these myths and I'm talking about
myths popular very famous beloved myths
like jason and the argonauts stories
about the sorceress Medea and the bronze
robot Talos who guarded the island of
Crete the legendary craftsman Daedalus
and Prometheus who was known as the fire
bringer and then Pandora the female the
artificial female who was created by the
god of technology and invention have
Festus and these were very vivid myths
and I think of them as sort of ancient
thought experiments kind of set in a an
alternate world where technology was
marvelously advanced because it's divine
so it's it's the
God's making these beings that are made
not born
made by bio Technic but in the last
chapter of my book I do talk about the
genuine self moving devices and
automatons that were actually fabricated
and made by real inventors and craftsmen
beginning in the 4th century BC so even
that goes back much earlier than people
have recognized yeah I mean I want to
hear all these stories because I all
these stories are fantastic but just to
set the stage a little bit maybe what
would be the way that a person who lived
in the fifth century BC thought about
technology I mean did they think of
machines as a thing There is obviously
simple machines levers and so forth are
being invented back in those days but
these days in our lives technological
advance is very important to us is that
a concept that they would have had it's
interesting what their technology and
machines was used for in the practical
world it's amusing that they didn't use
them in their everyday life but they
used them in warfare and in the theater
so there are machines to raise curtains
and to bring things onto the stage just
so that it looks sort of magical and
then there are torsion catapults and
other siege machines that use technology
but for everyday life not so much unless
you consider things like the bow and
arrow and things like that as human
enhancement machines in a way they sort
of are but I think most people when they
thought of technology they thought of
people doing metalwork and things like
that so and the god Hephaestus of course
was a blacksmith god he's the only God
with a job if you think about it I mean
he's always described as he's sweating
over his work and he's surrounded by his
tools and what's interesting is that
when he's described in the literature
and the myths or in the literature or in
depicted in ancient based paintings
Hephaestus is always shown working
surrounded by his tools and he was
thought of by ordinary people as using
the same tools the same materials the
same methods that an ordinary craftsman
would be using in his workshop on earth
but of course he's a God so that his his
productions are gonna just be marvelous
and awesome yeah I mean it that's very
interesting point that they would have
been used to the products of
craftsmanship right but the actual
something that is like a machine in a
more modern sense would have been
limited to when they went to the theater
or when they went to war something like
that so they knew about them but they
weren't household devices I guess we
should say that's that's generally true
on the other hand they probably saw some
moving statues of gods in temples
because we do have some descriptions of
animated statues at a very early date
and that would be that would be feasible
either with or without if it's a machine
it means that there's no one there
actually moving the moving the parts but
you could use steam or lovers Springs
weights things like that to cause a
statue to blink its eyes for instance or
move its arm hold out its hands or cry
or sweat or bleed things like that they
could make statues that were animated in
that way and if you think about it
there's almost a an uncanny valley
effect that goes all the way back to
this to these times of Homer yeah that
would've been very spooky to see us have
a moving statue especially back in the
days when the idea of machines was not
commonplace right the uncanny valley
effect was first identified I think in
1970 by Massa here Masahiro mori the
Japanese robot assist and it describes
that eerie sensation that we have when
we encounter really hyper hyper
realistic robots yeah but that I found
many examples in Homer's Odyssey
Illiad of people who have that same
eerie disquieting but sort of religious
awe about hyperrealism of the statues
and paintings in antiquity and and of
course now we know that all these
statues not just the marble ones but
even the bronze ones were painted
realistically and they weren't painted
with these garish colors that you see as
the reconstructions now that they know
what kind of paints they were and colors
they they mixed wax with with the
pigments so that it it had a warm look
so that it looked real well I think I
was I was under the man from these
reconstructions that I've seen that they
were fairly cartoonish in some way but
you're saying they were a lot more
realistic than that they were much more
realistic they the recreations are just
taking the most the most strict hue of
the pigment that they have found but we
know that they were very
realistic-looking
and they even had inlaid eyelashes and
eyes and pupils and inlaid fingernails I
mean these were realistic statues if you
think about seeing these in a temple
they're life-sized they're painted
realistically they're in a realistic
pose and there's if you go there at
night there there's no there's no light
except from an oil lamp or perhaps the
moon so you would have that uncanny
valley effect so yes so the audience
would have audience for this these
stories would be familiar with the ideas
of artificial creatures artificial human
beings it's very telling of course that
as soon as we imagine making artificial
machines we immediately imagine making
artificial people that's of course what
we're gonna do that's right and so they
start telling stories about them and you
know I would my idea was just to start
with the story of Talos because he's
clearly you know one of the stars of
your book and it made me go back and
watch some YouTube clips from the famous
jason and the argonauts movie from the
1960s I
I loved that movie and in fact the first
image in my book is an image of the of
the the great bronze robot from
that movie because someone made a bronze
cast of the original model and it shows
shows him crumbling and that's the jason
and the argonauts is really a cult film
now as 1963 I think but it's based on
ancient epic poem called the argonautica
about Jason the Argonauts
some some scholars think might be as old
or even older than Homer so we have a
story of a great bronze robot created by
Hephaestus the god of technology he tell
us was a huge urgent you could say giant
Android made of bronze he was charged
with defending Crete against invaders
and he patrolled King Minos Kingdom of
Crete by marching around the island
three times a day
someone has calculated that he would
have you would have to travel about 150
miles an hour to accomplish this feat
yeah where we're talking about ancient
science fiction's here right and so yeah
and and tell us was kind of programmed
by Hephaestus to repel invaders he had
several capabilities he could pick up
large rocks and throw them at intruders
he hurled boulders to sink any foreign
ships that he saw approaching creatures
and at clos in close combat he could
heat his bronze body to red-hot and then
grab up a victim and hug them to his
chest to roast them alive so he's he
does act like a robot he fits the
definition of a robot in that he can
carry out these activities but even even
more remarkably we know about his inner
workings and this is the first this is
the first description of a robot in
Greek literature and we know the details
of his inner workings apparently he was
built with a internal artery or vein
some sort of conduit that went from his
head to his feet and we even know his
power source
his power source was I Corps an AI Corps
of course is a mysterious
life Fluer to the gods that's what makes
them immortal so we've got AI core
pulsing through this single vein from
his neck to his to his ankle and this
bronze androids we could call it a
biomimetic viv assist him because it is
actually described as an artery using a
medical term the biological term for a
vein or artery and yet he's made a bomb
bronzed and the whole system is sealed
by a bronze bolt on his ankle
and so this is just a logical project
about product yeah no absolutely but but
just to put ourselves in the mood here I
guess people at that time didn't realize
that even for living organisms blood
circulated you know it went around and
around it came and went rather than just
going in one direction they hadn't quite
figured out as I read if I'm putting my
history of biology correctly is that
right
that's right but what's really
interesting is that I think I've cited a
study in in my book that shows that
people still have that kind of vision
about electricity or or the body but
especially like electricity we know that
it takes two wires to transmit and
conduct electricity and yet people still
think of it as a single pulsating fluid
or substance so majestic we still sort
of have that that sort of primitive view
it's so the author who's the author of
the argonautica the argonautica was was
a set of oral legends and myths and
tales or stories before it was ever
written down the first time it was
written down in its entirety for in a
surviving form was by Apollonius of
Rhodes a poet from the third century but
he was he was writing down what were
very old oral traditions but does seem
like whoever invented this story puts a
little bit of brain work into
how Talos would work it's kind of
impressive that it wasn't just magic
right it really was a machine yes and
that's what that's one of the
distinctions that I want to make clear
it when we talk about these automatons
and robots is that they they are
imagined as products of technology if
you think of metal metal working and the
way he's made of bronze and has inner
workings he's not brought to life by
magic every culture has these stories
including the including Greece but every
every ancient culture has stories of
inert matter
that's magically brought to life by some
sort of spell or maybe a gods command
you think of Adam and Eve or or even
Pygmalion and and his ivory statue she
was not made as an automaton or
technological being she was magically
brought to life by the goddess of love
so what I'm interested in is how these
mythological stories actually imagined
technological products synthetic
androids and artificial men and women
and animals yeah is it fair to imagine
that there's three categories here
there's sort of living organic beings
there are magically created creatures
and there's technologically created
creatures yes I think that's a pretty
good distinction the fact that they that
they describe Talos and Pandora and and
other of these artificial entities as
made not born I think that's a really
important distinction because it it
really draws the line between as you say
human non-human artificial and natural
and I think that they're really
emphasizing the manufactured nature of
tell us and then Pandora and I'm sure
that the boundary lines here are a
little fuzzy right I mean they didn't
exactly know what technology could do so
there's a little bit of magical thinking
going into it but also it there seemed
to be a little bit of ambiguity about
how human some of these machines were I
mean I know in the Ray Harryhausen movie
it seemed like tile
maybe has feelings you know or these had
some emotion like he feels bad when he's
being defeated is that fair to say
that's right I mean you could in the in
the original myth of Talos which was
actually the first written description
of tellus comes from Hesiod the poet
Hesiod who lived around the same time as
Homer so so tell us was first described
in about 700 BC and he is described as a
kind of I guess you could say cyborg
because he is sort of half human half
machine and and that line is is as you
say it's blurry and it's never really
resolved whether he is all machine you
know a sort of soulless machine or
whether he has a kind of consciousness
or emotions and that yeah the way the
way he's destroyed we can talk about
that - that sort of brings that all into
question - well it's definitely one of
the ways one of the many ways in which
the stories you recall in your book
prefigured debates were having right now
right you know what is the dividing line
between an artificial intelligence or a
conscious creature like an organic being
and they were I mean maybe they should
ask you rather than just guessing did
they ever wonder about that was were
there any ancient discussions about you
know at what point would an artificial
being count as human well I think the
story of Talos really brings that to the
forefront in though in the way he was
finally destroyed
he was destroyed because jason and the
argonauts were lucky enough to have
Medea who was kind of a techno wizard
had she had fallen in love with Jason so
she was along with them and she's the
one who figured out how to neutralize
Talos otherwise jason and the argonauts
would have would have been killed by
this killer robot Medea figures out okay
she knew his inner workings and she knew
that he was powered by AI core and that
I Corps bestows immortality on the gods
but she figured out the whole system
depends on that bolt on his ankle and if
I can get him to allow me to remove that
bolt then this immortal I Korff the
power fluid will bleed out and he will
be destroyed and so she she plays on his
emotions she persuades him
she tells Telos but she can make him
immortal and of course that's a kind of
human desire isn't it he wants to become
invulnerable he wants to go on forever
and she says I can make you immortal but
only if you allow me to remove that bolt
on your ankle and he agrees to that now
he's stepping out of the role of a pure
machine he's he's making a decision that
his makers and the people who deploy him
they weren't expecting him to be able to
have this kind of agency this kind of
desire and this kind of human ability to
make a bad decision yeah it seems like
bad programming on is the only he's
supposed to do was you know run around
Crete and throw boulders he wasn't
supposed to be thinking about
immortality that's right
but she persuaded him and she removes
she and Jason removed the bolt and we
know that this is a very ancient version
of the story because we have vase
paintings from the 5th century BC that
actually show Jason kneeling by this
large bronze man and he's using a tool
to remove the bolt on the bronze man's
ankle and tell us his swooning falling
back reeling off balance and you can see
that is made of bronze he's painted like
like ancient artists painted statues or
bronze armor and yet he's very humanized
his eyes are rolling up and one artist
actually painted a teardrop falling from
his I know they really did humanize him
even though they thought of him as made
of bronze so you've got all those
questions all those questions that seem
so modern to us are kind of embedded in
this story one of the things that is
absolutely characteristic to me of Greek
stories and I'm not an expert so you
know again fill me in but there's people
trying to do things and then getting
their their comeuppance for one way
together right
being hubristic trying to fly or cheat
immortality and then paying some sort of
terrible price so I love the fact that
even the Android even Talos the robots
know has this kind of human failing
that's right
yes he's she Medea is kind of like a
hacker she figures out his point of
weakness that vulnerability and she
exploit sit that I think that's an
interesting interesting little modern
lesson for us to him he's a product of
technology but he's taken down by
technology yeah it was a technological
solution to a technological problem very
clever
exactly everyone should have Medea on
their side of thing to be facing things
like this well from reading your book I
definitely get the feeling that Medea
deserves more credit than she gets in
the popular imagination I mean I think
of the play in the Euripides play and
she's killing her children and there's a
tragedy and things like that but you
know was over and over again saving
Jason from terrible things that's right
the journey to the Golden Fleece and and
as I like to call her a kind of techno
wizard because she is a sorceress she
has all this arcane knowledge of drugs
and biotechnology and she could
rejuvenate people in her famous special
golden cauldron by boiling powerful
herbs and other drugs she there's one
story that she she was asked by Jason to
restore his elderly father's youth and
you know all cultures have these stories
of the Fountain of Youth and
rejuvenation stories but the the one the
Greek story about Medea doing this is it
really has a lot of biotechnological
details in it somehow she drew all the
blood out of the old man's veins and
then replaced his blood with a sort of
secret
[ __ ] Tientsin daugther ingredients that
she brewed in her golden cauldron it's
really really quite amazing yeah I think
they're working on that in Silicon
Valley right now are they really are
this no this is they they are not just
thinking about rejuvenation and
extending human lifespan but looking
trying to think about immortality to
historians of surgeon surgery a point
have have pointed out that madea's sort
of imaginary experiment this is a myth
of course that it kind of foreshadows
modern blood transfusions I mean she
withdrew all of his blood and replaced
it so that that's sort of sort of a
prefiguring of what is called exchange
or substitution transfusion where
patients it completely bled out and then
replaced with a donors blood and I in
the past I think 15 years some blood
exchange experiment experiments have
been carried out with young and old mice
and they've been shown to rejuvenate the
muscles in the livers of the older mice
when their blood is replaced with that
of young mice and so there are some
startup companies here in Silicon Valley
that are pretty excited about this I
think someone just issued a warrant I
think there's some large health
institution issued a warning saying that
this wasn't probably not a good idea yet
they're not yet you know forward
thinking people are always gonna take
the risks but I wonder you know again in
contemporary culture we think of science
fiction as trading back and forth with
technological advance sometimes a
technological advance is inspired by
science fiction sometimes it's the other
way around do you think there is any
similar dynamic going on back then do
you think that there is any slightly
overly ambitious doctor who might have
tried a blood transfusion based on
stories like this or was it just a guess
on the base of the poet I don't really
know how they would actually be able to
try
a blood transfusion like that I think it
was pretty imaginary in this myth but
there are stories of people making
models of birds wings
our kites in order to fly and you know
if you think about the story of Daedalus
and his son Icarus Daedalus wanted to
escape with his son he was he and his
son were imprisoned by Minos in the
labyrinth that Daedalus had built
himself with the now it's a prison for
him he wants to escape so he he's a
legendary brilliant craftsman not a god
he's imagined as a human
he makes imitation bird wings and he and
his son fly off he anticipates that the
weak points of his artificial wings he
tells his son don't don't fly too high
or the heat will melt the glue or the
wax don't fly too low near the ocean the
ocean dampness will weaken the glue and
of course Icarus he experiences the
rapture of flight and he flies higher
and higher and of course we all know the
story that he plunged into the sea and
sometimes I was taken as a story of
hubris and that they got what they got
what they deserved for playing God by
trying to fly but if you think about it
a little deeper Daedalus mourns his son
and then he flies on he ends up in
Sicily he escapes and continues his his
a wonderful resume of of marvellous
animated statue so they both did succeed
in flying but at a very high cost I
think maybe that's the that would be the
lesson to take from that story yeah I
mean Daedalus sacrificed his son in the
name of scientific experimentation well
you know sometimes that can make an
omelet without breaking a few eggs
that's right and it's interesting that
he anticipated the weak points of his
invention too so yeah I think these days
were romantically invested in the Icarus
part of the myth but again Daedalus
credit you know he really and he really
figured a whole bunch of stuff out at
least according to the stories and one
of the things I wanted to ask was that's
at least something
where there's a chance that there he was
based on the real person or real people
right yeah some people some scholars
have suggested that Daedalus was sort of
meant as a kind of conglomerate of all
the brilliant craftsman who did actually
invent technologies or animated statues
things like that and so he sort of
stands for stands for all of those real
artisans and craftspeople and everybody
wanted to claim
Daedalus Crete claimed him and then
Sicily claimed him and then Athens the
city of Athens actually revised all the
myths to make to make Athens his
birthplace so everybody wanted him as a
sort of founding inventor and so what
what are the inventions he's credited
with I mean the wings obviously the
labyrinth which doesn't seem like as
hard as making wings that will make
people fly but yes is it like you said a
long resume of inventions to his name
well one of the most infamous of his
inventions was the artificial cow that
he made for Queen Paso Fay oh yeah she
was with a perverse desire to mate with
a bull in her husband King Minos as
pastures she felt the gods made her fall
in love with with the bull and so she
asked Daedalus to make her an artificial
cow so that she could enter the cow and
in that way fool the bull into having
sex with pass a fee inside the cow this
was there are hundreds of images of this
myth he is my favorite subject for
artists it's really interesting in the
middle in the Middle Ages it was also
possible I also um popular and they but
they've they focus on the actual love
story between the pacify and the bowl so
that's a show her bringing flowers to
this sort of lovesick bull but that's a
kind of sex toy if you think about it I
mean
she animates it by getting inside so
it's a kind of animated statue anyway
that was one of date Alyssa's marvelous
invention but then then she gave birth
yes unfortunately she gave birth to a
the Minotaur and there there's a vase
painting showing the baby Minotaur I
mean we don't have very many we don't
have very many images of baby monsters
there but there was a vase painting that
shows the baby Minotaur sitting on
passive phase lap and she has a very
startled look on her face and that her
gesture is one of anxiety it's a good
reminder that even the monster Minotaur
was a baby once he had a mommy who loved
him but so what and what else did
Daedalus do after but also Daedalus then
invented the the labyrinth as a as a
place where they could in King Minos
could imprison his stepson the Minotaur
it is very interesting to be reading
your book how much of what we know is
not just textual but based on these
artistic depictions on you know pottery
and so forth it's the it was it's clear
that there is a set of stories that
every artist in the ancient Greek and
Roman world knew and just loved painting
yes and it it also it's very helpful
because we have to think of just I
realize how much of Greek literature has
been lost a lot of a lot of these myths
we only have incomplete texts or
fragments and so the vase paintings can
can give us hints about what has been
lost and versions of the story that have
been lost so they could also confirm
things like the the vase painting I
mentioned of Jason using a tool to
remove the bolt on tell us as ankle
that's important for showing just how
old that story was right right and it
but it goes back even further than that
right and so there's there's a section
in your book about
Prometheus the Titan constructing if you
want to put it that way human the human
race itself right so is there a sense in
which we human beings count as you know
robots in the sense that we were
originally created rather than born
that's a of course a very deep
philosophical question and so are we all
are we all robots and in fact Plato does
bring that up in one of his dialogues he
says let let us imagine that we are
puppets made by a capricious God so they
they thought about those questions and
of course I think that in Buddhist
cultures they have different ideas about
robots and automatons then than Western
cultures I haven't delved too deeply
into this but the the few ancient
stories that I did find that were
Buddhist texts about automatons the
messages seem to be something like we
are all robots let's don't have souls
and neither do we so I think that that
would be very interesting to look deeper
it's always a little tricky right
because obviously they didn't have the
exact words robots and Android and
cyborg or something like that so we have
to sort of remember that they were just
talking about exactly the same concept
in different words that we would use
right and recently I was writing about
the the ancient legend from India about
Buddha's relics his bodily remains being
guarded in antiquity right after he died
by a set of robotic warriors and they
had they did have a word for what we
would call robot or automaton they
called them spirit movement machines
they had a word for machine and they
call them spirit movement machines and
they had a word for robot makers so yes
a it's really hard to tease these words
out you
have to do a lot of reading these things
are not indexed do you think that spirit
mover machine what is the word spirit
doing in there I think that that
emphasizes the the mysterious origins of
their movements okay but the fact that
they are machine they the third word is
machine Yantra which means mechanism
mechanized entity well it's clear you
know from your book that many of the
uses that people imagine for these
artificial beings is wartime right you
know fighting battles I guess you know
I'm not sure whether there were lots of
battles being fought or whether just
when he went down to write stories it
was the most fun to write about battles
but clearly they're stories of
artificial soldiers and elephants it's a
lot of fun really
yes well the and as we mentioned earlier
a lot of the Greek technology was
focused on making novel war machines so
various rulers did actually hold
contests for artisans and inventors to
make doesn't make design and make
innovations in war machines and that's
how philip ii came up with the torsion
catapult
he held a contest for that you know this
kind of this brings us to the question
that many people are worried about today
is that does technology favor tyranny or
totalitarianism yeah yeah I I went into
much more benign direction I thought of
the XPrize yes you know it's interesting
if you think about Hephaestus the me the
wonders that he made in his workshop
many of them were for the gods and
goddesses they called on him when they
required devices with some spectacular
features and magnificent beauty and
craftsmanship he created Telos but he
also had a big list of wonders long
resume he he made golden hunting dogs
animated statues of watchdog
that were described in Homer's Odyssey
and Homer's Iliad tells us that
Hephaestus made a set of automated
bellows for his Forge these bellows
could obey his commands and regulate
their blasts - to blow more or less air
as he worked and then he devised a
wondrous fleet of these tables or tables
tripods three-legged tables on wheels
that were self-driving carts they
brought nectar and ambrosia to the gods
and goddesses at their banquets and they
returned when they were empty and he
made automatic gates from Mount Olympus
the heavens that would automatically
open and close these are no driverless
carts and automated garage doors oh he
also made a team of life-sized golden
maids to serve as his assistants and
Homer describes these robotic servants
as looking exactly like real young women
but that they were endowed with sense
and reason and that they were equipped
with all the knowledge of the gods and
in other words then that's a that
amounts to a mythological version of
artificial intelligence and that's
written more than 2,500 years ago but
just as you said when you first asked
this question these things are all very
benign and harmless and kind of charming
kind of fun to imagine it's when it's
when these made not born things come
down to earth like Talos or Pandora that
they well Asimov's laws get broken
destruction and chaos well it's also
it's very interesting to me that have
faced us who's clearly sort of based on
a super blacksmith right you know
someone who would Forge weapons and
armor and things like that
clearly I guess you know they imagined
if you're a god and a blacksmith then
you're also a wizard inventor you know
even at a time when inventing new things
was not common currency yeah and as you
mentioned before I think there was a lot
of
overlap between magic and technology and
antiquity especially with metalworking
because just the things you could do
with bronze to an ordinary person would
seem like magic and using fire and
molten metals and forging something that
can move or look real and you could even
use real things to cast bronze so that
that's one of the things that Daedalus
was famous for was that he he made a
golden honeycomb that looked exactly
like a honeycomb well that's right
that's what a goldsmith could do if they
cast the gold on a real honeycomb but it
seemed like magic in antiquity I do I
have more things about Hephaestus to
talk about but I don't want to before I
forget I want to go back to Jason
because I forgot about the dragon's
teeth store which is a great one again
has amazing modern resonances yes it
does
Jason had to accomplish these impossible
tasks in in the myth of the gist of the
quest for the golden fleece and one of
them was that he had to tame or somehow
subdue a pair of Robo bronze bulls these
were robot bulls made of bronze created
by Hephaestus for the king who happened
to be madea's father he's the one who
set this task for Jason and he said you
need to yoke these bronze fire-breathing
bulls and then plough a field oh and
here's a helmet full of dragon's teeth
you need to plant these dragon's teeth
in the furrows and from these dragon's
teeth will spring up an unnatural army
and that's the crop that you will have
to harvest you need to cut down that
army and even compla
that by nightfall then then I'll tell
you where the Golden Fleece is you know
we make fun of James Bond movies for
heaven
come up with these cockamamie schemes he
clearly goes back a long time
absolutely Madea
creates a special drug once again made
from I Corps to give Jason superhuman
power this is like a human enhancement
that she makes in drug form for Jason so
that he can overpower the those bronze
bulls that are snorting fire the effect
only lasts one days but gives him
superhuman strength and the description
in the myth is quite interesting you
know he sounds like he's turning into
the Hulk he's normally a very skinny guy
as we see in vase painting zc owners are
very unassuming physique but she gives
him him this drug and he turns into a
strong man able to do all these tasks
and sure enough by the my dusk they see
that these soldiers are popping up fully
armed unnatural army popping up out of
the furrows that he has plowed and
planted the dragon's teeth and now these
soldiers are they're fully armed and
they're programmed to attack they can't
be commanded or led and they can't stop
or halt or change direction they can
only attack so once again Medea to the
rescue she figures out their
vulnerabilities and she advises Jason to
throw rocks into their into their midst
and he does that and it it works just
like Medea said it would they feel the
blows our sense the blows on their
shields and believe that they're being
attacked and they're programmed to
attack and so they attack whatever is
closest to them they attack each other
so they're just they're just in a frenzy
of hacking at each other and then jason
and the argonauts go and finish them off
so once again Madea Madea is the one you
want on your side and it's that's a very
realistic sort of technological worry
about you know
slightly bad programming right I don't
know if you know the story of the the
Lord of the Rings movies yes so you know
they had all these these armies orcs
orcs that were all CGI and they
programmed them individually to sort of
make it look realistic but some of them
would just sort of look for the nearest
person to fight and didn't didn't see
any ones just would run away from the
battles and it looks like the whole org
army was just running to the three wins
so these programming these instructions
actually is a harder trick than it might
seem like that's right and and what
happens if you want to actually if the
circumstances change and you need to
reprogram them or interrupt their train
of behavior pretty difficult one ancient
writer said well every general would
want to but would want an army like this
but I I don't think so yeah there's some
judgement very very difficult to to
control if if the circumstances suddenly
change and as some people have said we
need to make AI artificial intelligence
that knows when to ask for help
you're my human I mean I probably know
the answer to this but did any of these
ancient sources go into any detail at
all about programming or how the
instructions were put into these robots
you know that once again I'm going to
I'm going to appeal to the fact that we
have such incomplete record we do have
so many details about Talos and yet for
many of the others we don't have we
don't have the details that that might
have existed in antiquity I haven't I
haven't found any examples of details of
programming how yeah that would be very
pretty advanced I wouldn't be surprised
if it wasn't there but I mean oh he may
be curious well there there is an
interesting recent discovery of a
papyrus that tells us it was founded in
the 70s I believe that has a story of a
guardian lion that was built by
Hephaestus to guard an Aegean Island
the papyrus says that special
instructions for the benefits benefit of
all mankind were placed in the lion so
there's a there's a that's an that's the
most beneficial AI robot that I know of
from antiquity that came to earth that
was put placed on earth it's the only
beneficial one I can think but was
programmed by Hephaestus to be a benefit
to all mankind well yeah so speaking of
the person speaking of benefits to all
mankind I was trying to think of you
know how to sort of characterize all of
the different kinds of robots and AIS
that he talked about in the book so
there's androids right there's robots in
human form there's human enhancement
like what Daedalus does with the wings
and and the various attempts at
immortality through blood transfusions
and then of course there are sex robots
yes and we can thank investors for that
is that right that's right of hephaestus
once again is commissioned by Zeus who
is always portrayed as a very vindictive
harsh tyrant in these myths so once
again there you have tyrants seeking out
people who can make technology he wants
he wants to punish humankind for
accepting the gift of fire from
prometheus Prometheus not only made
humans but then wanted to defend them
and compensate for their involve or
their vulnerability by giving them the
technology of fire well he was punished
for that and Zeus then wants to punish
humans as well so he asks Hephaestus to
make an artificial woman as beautiful as
a goddess and but he said he
specifically says that this entity who
is made not born will arouse lust in men
and she will be evil described and
disguised as beauty so she is she's a an
evil fembot who is created by Hephaestus
specifically to carry out a mission on
earth she has this sealed jar or urn
later became a box in the Middle Ages
because of a mistranslation but she has
a mission on earth she is to insinuate
herself in human society and then unseal
that jar releasing all the miseries and
sufferings of mankind and then we never
hear over again well I have this vague
feeling that I was taught that Pandora
was the first woman almost like a
precursor to Eve in some versions of the
story or they're different versions or
which she always robotic or the once
again the boundary lines just very
blurry here in the very earliest text we
have of the story of Pandora comes from
Hesiod the poet epic poet Hesiod who
wrote the story twice in two different
works in about 700 BC he lives in around
the time of Homer so this is an
extremely ancient story and once again
he's he's drawing on oral traditions and
he just he does not describe her as the
first woman he describes her as made not
born and a product of technology from
the very beginning she's not said to be
the first woman but I think she gets
sort of overlaps with Eve as the story
gets perpetuated we all think of the
sort of a very benign fairy tale version
of Pandora that she was a an innocent
young woman who just couldn't restrain
her curiosity and that that is not the
original story at all yeah and I mean
it's I'm going to return to this theme
once again because I think it's very
interesting about how many of these
stories are ultimately cautionary tales
right and it's weird to think that they
were cautionary tales about the dangers
of Technology
dangers were not very manifest at the
time that's right but as I say these are
kind of science fiction so they're
imagining what what wonders could be
created if only possessed the creativity
and the divine abilities of the gods or
someone like Medea so
yeah that's right it's it is interesting
that they seem to be cautionary they do
they do have lessons for us is it is it
just the idea that reaching too far and
being hubristic is is something to be
warned against and this idea of
manipulating nature through technology
is just one illustration of that well I
I did notice that and I think I just
mentioned earlier that these self moving
devices and automatons that have festus
made for the use his own use and the use
of the gods and goddesses in heaven are
all harmless and benign and charming but
the ones that are sent to earth to
interact with humans are dangerous we've
got the killer robot Telus and Pandora
and then the various guard dogs and
lions and creatures like that so maybe
maybe this lesson in the myths or
something that we can draw from them is
that maybe they're trying to say that
it's interesting to think about in a
sort of abstract way but if if these
technologies are going to interact with
humans we need to think them over and of
course the story of Pandora really
emphasizes that when you think about the
relationship between Prometheus and his
brother Epimetheus in that story
Pandora the relationship was yeah yeah
they're they're brothers Prometheus and
Epimetheus Prometheus is the one who
made the humans and then gave them fire
his name means foresight he looks ahead
his brother Epimetheus his name means
hindsight he's short-sighted he never
looks ahead capable of humor and Dustin
by your name certain characteristics
like maybe they were named later I don't
know but so Epimetheus is the perfect
Patsy
for Zeus's trick on humans this cruel
trick that he's going to play
he sends Hermes the messenger God to
escort Pandora down to to earth and he
presents Pandora as a bride to
Epimetheus and Epimetheus is dazzled by
her beauty but Prometheus tries to stop
him from accepting this gift he says
this isn't a gift do not accept any
gifts from Zeus please do not do this
and Epimetheus shrugs him off and goes
for the short-term gain and as Hesiod
the poet in 700 BC tells us he realized
his error too late is it is it is there
also some sort of warning against the
wiles of women going on here is is it
mostly technological you think I think
that it could be interpreted that way
but mostly I think it's a story of
caution I mean when you think about the
role of Hope in the story of Pandora now
if we think of the fairy tale version
we've all seen the illustrations of
Pandora sort of reeling back in horror
when she opens this sealed box or jar
but actually that was her mission and
the last thing in her jar and that in
that sealed vessel it was hope right
yeah
and we're used to seeing illustrations
from fairy tales European fairy tales
that Joe hope is the sort of beautiful
fairy who arise it flies up out of the
jar and comforts humankind but that's
once again that's not what the original
myth said in antiquity Greeks did not
think of hope as a good thing
hope was called blind hope it robs you a
foresight it makes you into an epimer
thean character you can never look ahead
so they really and they really thought
we know that they really thought about
that a lot because there are some
fragments of plays about Pandora
and Prometheus where prometheus talks
about the meaning of hope and blind hope
and the question unresolved in the play
and in philosophical arguments was hope
the best thing or the worst thing in
Pandora's jars is hope a good thing for
humans or a bad thing for humans I mean
is it would it be fair to say that the
meaning of Hope in this context is
closer to something like wishful
thinking I think so yes we certainly
have a lot of Epimetheus types in AI and
robotics who who assure us that we're so
innovative and creative that will will
we'll be fine we'll be able to solve all
the problems that as they come up and
then we have Prometheans who say we need
to step back and try to think about
unexpected unintended consequences if we
possibly can
yeah the two attitudes are never going
to go away they just need to be in
conversation with each other in an
intelligent way so which is all we can
hope for now I'm sure there's many other
stories that are in your wonderful book
and I encourage everyone to buy it but
in our last few minutes here I wanted to
completely switch topics mainly it's not
a complete switch you tell me but you've
written a whole nother book which I
thought was fascinating about Amazon's
and I've seen Wonder Woman you know I
know about the Amazons but I think I
haven't read that one I'll confess but I
think you make the case that the myth of
the Amazons was based to a surprising
degree on real-life events is that right
yes I I make that case in my book the
Amazons lives and legends of warrior
women across the ancient world if you've
heard of the myths of Amazon's then you
know that they were fierce warrior women
from exotic lands to the east they lived
around the Black Sea and beyond all the
way to Central Asia and what I wanted to
emphasize is that the myths of the
Amazons were probably influenced by real
women who rode to war along side the men
in
cultures around the Black Seas on the
steps that were known to the ancient
Greeks and that their lifestyle was so
egalitarian when it came to male and
female roles that the Greeks really spun
many exciting stories about Amazon's and
the reason I feel I could make that
argument is that there are some
spectacular and recent archaeological
discoveries of the graves of hundreds of
battle-scarred female skeletons buried
with weapons
just like the men given honors like the
males and buried with their weapons and
their horses in about the 5th century BC
and onwards all across the steppes
around the Black Sea and so it's not
that there was an entire society of
nothing but women warriors which sorta
yeah but that would be reasonable for
all sorts of reasons for all sorts of
reasons yes and even the Greeks told
other stories about Amazon's who
actually did have relationships with men
in their myths but the exaggerated
exaggeration of the cingulate arianism
led to stories of society of nothing but
women and part of it was just that you
know the Greek fighting style which was
sort of kind of brutish and hand-to-hand
would naturally favor the you know
taller stronger men whereas the
societies the cultures on the steppes
were more riding on horseback shooting
bows and arrows things that women could
do just as well as men could absolutely
the the Greek style of warfare was on
foot heavily armed all armed exactly the
same and all taught the same tactics
hoplite soldiers who would march in a
phalanx out to meet the enemy who would
be another force of similarly armed and
trained men but the Scythian 's these
their ancestors were the people who
domesticated the horse and perfected the
recurve bow so these these cultures of
Scythian nomads
very diverse cultures but they were
culturally related because they all were
centered on archery and riding horses
and if you put a woman on a horse with a
bow and arrow she's just as fast just as
deadly as a man and their lifestyle was
egalitarian because it was a necessity
for their survival everyone in the tribe
learned to ride horses when they're
toddlers and they learned to shoot bows
and arrows everyone could hunt everyone
could defend the tribe it's just a
necessity so and this and they dressed
the same in long pants or leggings
trousers because you have to have those
to ride a horse and long sleeves very
practical activewear for both the men
and women and their whole society just
astounded the Greeks because they kept
their women at home weaving and taking
care of children they didn't have an
outdoor life at all so everyone thinks
that their own local customs should be
laws of nature right so yeah other
people do it differently is hard to
fathom that's right so I think that that
led to of this outpouring of Amazon
tales which every everyone knew these
stories by heart they they knew about
all the stories of their their greatest
Greek heroes had to prove themselves by
fighting noble enemies right now those
among those noble enemies were the
Amazon Queens it's a so I mean both of
these big stories the one about the
robots and artificial intelligence ideas
in antiquity and about the Amazons
they're a wonderful reminder of how the
debates that we have in the modern world
are prefigured and debates we've been
having for a very very very long time
right and I think it's a wonderful
example in both cases of how we can
still learn and expand our minds and
maybe make ourselves a little bit more
cultured by remembering what people were
debating about 2,000 and 3,000 years ago
absolutely all right Hadrian er thanks
so much for being on the podcast thank
you
[Music]
you
[Music]